[Aplausos]
[Música]
el pasado 26 de noviembre de 2017 hubo
elecciones en honduras elecciones un
tanto particulares aunque millones de
personas estaban llamadas a votar ese
día al final sólo contó un voto el del
presidente juan orlando hernández que
decidió quedarse otros cuatro años más
dijeran lo que dijeran las urnas joe
juan orlando hernández
voy a hacer lo que tenga que hacer para
recuperar la paz y la tranquilidad de
mis pueblos
[Música]
si vamos que es muy posible que el
presidente hernández se dijese a sí
mismo oye si a mí me gusta esto de ser
presidente porque dejarlo no no algo
habrá que hacerlo desde entonces las
protestas ante lo que todo apunta ha
sido un pucherazo un robo un asalto a la
democracia se han sucedido con bastante
intensidad en un país amigos honduras
que ya de por sí sufre como pocos las
trágicas consecuencias de un modelo
social y político cocinado con mucha
corrupción y mucha violencia un modelo
tan desastroso y disfuncional que ha
hecho que honduras sea el país ojo más
pobre de latinoamérica y el tercer país
no en guerra más peligroso del mundo
[Música]
veréis honduras es un pequeño país
tropical con poco más de 9 millones de
habitantes situado en un estrecho trozo
de tierra que separa al mar caribe del
océano pacifico si para que nos
entendamos honduras es uno de esos
lugares en los que podemos encontrar a
algunas de esas playas que todos tenemos
grabadas en nuestra imaginación playas
de arena blanca agua cristalina y muchos
cocoteros
[Música]
suena bien verdad desgraciadamente
amigos el narcotráfico las pandillas y
una élite política y económica que han
priorizado por encima de todo el saqueo
de los recursos nacionales han
enturbiado manchado la realidad de un
país que de otra forma podría estar
seguro luchando por ser considerado un
auténtico paraíso en la tierra cuando
van a cambiar en varios ejes de una
visión de nuestra familia dando cuenta
de que eres gay members con este tema de
conexión menos antes de sanfermines
topic ground snacks en el término de tve
[Música]
pero bien puede que estéis pensando un
país pequeño remoto
pobre bueno una historia más una
historia de tantas otras verdad pues
esperas un momento porque aquí hay mucho
pero que mucho más
[Música]
qué pensaríais si os digo que es posible
que estemos ante el primer golpe de
estado apoyado por la administración
trump atentos
[Música]
el fraude
el domingo 26 de diciembre de 2017 se
celebraron elecciones generales en
honduras a la presidencia el cargo con
diferencia más importante tuvo
fundamentalmente dos grandes
contendientes por un lado el presidente
juan orlando hernández que ha apoyado
ampliamente por la cúpula económica del
país y también por la comunidad
internacional aspiraba a ser reelegido
una reelección que por cierto ha sido
muy polémica porque en principio la
constitución del país la impide en su
artículo 239 un artículo que en 2015 sin
embargo fue declarada inaplicable por un
fallo sorprendente y muy pero que muy
controvertido de la corte suprema- un
órgano que por cierto está controlado
por el presidente si puede que eso haya
tenido algo que ver es que la corte
suprema de justicia en la sala
constitucional no está facultada para
declarar inconstitucional la
constitución misma atentos a lo que
decía este artículo 239 el ciudadano que
haya desempeñado la titularidad del
poder ejecutivo no podrá ser presidente
o designado bien por
2 salvador nasralá un popular
presentador de televisión que se postuló
como candidato de una coalición de
partidos de centroizquierda la alianza
de oposición le voy a quitar el
terrorismo fiscal que en una dictadura
olvídense si en este momento los tiene
trabados del gobierno si se consolidó
una dictadura se acaba la empresa
privada y más temprano que tarde ustedes
perderán incluso sus empresas conmigo la
vara con a conservar pues bien el caso
es que los momentos iniciales del
recuento de votos todo apuntaba a la
victoria de salvador nasralá fijaos
con casi el 60 por ciento del voto
escrutado lograba una diferencia de
cinco puntos sobre el presidente una
ventaja tan contundente que los propios
magistrados que forman el tribunal
supremo electoral de honduras
calificaron esta situación ante los
representantes de la organización de
estados américanos como irreversible
insalvable
sin embargo de repente el recuento se
para usted dejaron de tener datos los
sistemas informáticos se cayeron
aparecieron papeletas por contar y al
final varios días más tarde el tribunal
electoral le otorgó la victoria sorpresa
al presidente juan orlando hernández
cuando están contando los votos y el
presidente del tribunal electoral dice
se cayó el sistema como ocurrió con
honduras es que hay de toda la manera
para meter la mano las irregularidades
fueron tantas que la propia organización
de estados américanos ha rechazado el
recuento y ha pedido nuevas elecciones
el secretario general de la organización
de estados americanos luis almagro
publicó en sus redes sociales que la oea
propone nuevas elecciones para
garantizar paz y concordia en ese país
ante imposibilidad de dar certeza a
resultados electorales pero ahí no
termina todo el semanario the economist
publicó en su página web un día antes de
las elecciones que tenía una grabación
que acreditaba que el gobierno se estaba
preparando para ganar o ganar
en fin hubo pucherazo es difícil
asegurarlo pero las probabilidades de
que esto ocurriese son muy pero que muy
altas todo ello por no hablar del
comportamiento autoritario que el
gobierno ha tenido claro una vez que la
sospecha de amaño electoral estaba sobre
la mesa la oposición pues se movilizó y
organizó concentraciones de protesta en
un primer momento fueron pacíficas algo
que no le importó a la policía para
emplear la mano más dura
[Aplausos]
por ejemplo la noche del miércoles 29
las fuerzas del estado lanzaron gases
lacrimógenos sobre una concentración de
unas 1000 personas que estaban esperando
pacíficamente los resultados y en la que
se encontraba el candidato opositor
a la policía no le importo que fuese una
concentración pacífica ni que hubiese
niños y personas mayores
[Aplausos]
huang orlando está provocando
enfrentamientos entre el mismo pueblo
con los policías y no es justo esto
tiene que terminar esto lo tiene que
saber todo el mundo que fue orlando es
un dictador y no se quede aquí
[Música]
bueno el gobierno e incluso decretó el
toque de queda y desde entonces las
concentraciones se han saldado según las
informaciones de amistad internacional
con la pérdida de 14 vidas y más de 800
detenidos vamos en otras palabras las
pruebas parecen apuntar a un claro
pucherazo electoral seguido de un
proceso de represión y uso de la fuerza
para que para apuntalar esta victoria
con lo que andamos en las calles es que
juan orlando hernández tiene que estar
in our a sabes por qué porque hace
cuatro años dijo nadie está por encima
de la ley y a lo que nosotros estamos
peleando ahora bien dicho esto tenemos
varias preguntas por contestar y una de
ellas claramente es quién es exactamente
el presidente quién es juan orlando
hernández
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el presidente hay dos versiones dos
interpretaciones muy diferentes sobre la
figura del presidente hernández la
primera es la de un líder con mano dura
pero que fue capaz de rescatar a su país
de convertirse en un estado fallido la
segunda es la de un líder autoritario
vinculado con la corrupción y el crimen
un líder que se ha hecho con el control
de las instituciones del país y las
maneja a su antojo conforme a sus
intereses como hemos visto con la corte
suprema y la reelección vengo de la
tierra de lempiras
mano de dios
[Música]
y el pueblo hondureño
sin embargo el presidente luego lo vamos
a ver con más detalle tiene el apoyo
entre otros de eeuu y para ser justos
hay que decir que su mandato ha tenido
muchas sombras pero también algunas
luces empecemos con estas con las luces
[Música]
fijaos cuando juan orlando hernández
llegó al poder en 2013 honduras era el
país no en guerra con la tasa de
homicidios más alta honduras era el país
no en guerra más mortífero del mundo
cada 13 horas
en sixty per cent hoy es verdad el país
sigue tenido un grave problema sigue
siendo el tercer país con más homicidios
en relación a su población y el 90% de
estos crímenes permanecen impunes pero
la cosa ha mejorado de hecho eso es
prácticamente logro por el que este
presidente saca pecho
con la ayuda de los eeuu el gobierno
hondureño creó nuevos cuerpos especiales
de policía financiados equipados y
entrenados por la dea y el fbi entre
otros cuerpos al mismo tiempo ha
expulsado y reemplaza a miles de agentes
corruptos ha desmantelado varios
cárteles de la droga y extraditó a
decenas de narcotraficantes a estados
unidos e incluso ha creado por todo el
país parques vigilados por la policía
militar para que niños y familias puedan
disfrutar del tiempo libre con cierta
seguridad en esta lucha no hay retroceso
no daremos un tan solo paso atrás hasta
que este país vivo en paz y tranquilidad
como nos lo merecemos hasta aquí todo
bien verdad
desgraciadamente amigos la historia no
termina si tú
hay pruebas claras de la corrupción del
presidente de hecho la campaña electoral
de 2013 que le llevó al poder fue
financiada por dinero sustraído ni más
ni menos que del instituto hondureño de
la seguridad social e incluso si hay
sospechas fundadas de que el presidente
orlando ha tenido relaciones con grupos
de narcotraficantes como por ejemplo los
casinos el comercio ilícito de drogas en
honduras no sólo afectó a gran parte de
la sociedad civil e incluso a los
niveles más altos del gobierno y el
sector financiero sino que también
permitió que su gente quedará expuesta a
terribles niveles de violencia y un kim
fiscal estadounidense en cualquier caso
sean o no ciertas estas acusaciones y
ahora me dirijo a usted presidente
hernández la represión el engaño y el
control de las instituciones ni pueden
justificarse ni contribuyen a que
honduras pueda superar los problemas que
frenan su desarrollo usted ha tenido un
apoyo claro de la comunidad
internacional ha recibido dinero ayuda
policial y militar y respaldo político y
la verdad creo que se esperaba algo
distinto claro que amigos desgracia
todo esto no es algo extraño en este
país
un cóctel de corrupción y violencia
honduras tiene un problema muy pero que
muy difícil de combatir
existe un triángulo de poderes
interrelacionados que hacen que en
honduras ser optimista sea un reto
difícil el poder político la oligarquía
económica y los narcos
tal vez el caso más representativo de
todo sea el de fabio logo el hijo de
porfirio lobo- el anterior presidente de
la república que acaba de ser condenado
en eeuu a 24 años de cárcel por sus
vínculos y actividades como
narcotraficante unas actividades que
desempeñó cuando su padre era atentos el
mismísimo presidente de la república y
no no hablamos de un hijo rebelde ni
nada por el estilo
por cierto el narcotráfico es hoy la
primera actividad económica de honduras
mi hijo es un abogado y notario público
tenía puesto su bufete con el trabajo de
muchas instituciones e incluso
instituciones financieras otro ejemplo
tal y como cuenta el new york times'
está en el parlamento en el congreso un
edificio de los años 50 infra equipado
que carece de las mínimas condiciones
necesarias y que contrasta con el
parking de los señores diputados el
estacionamiento amigos está lleno de
vehículos todo-terreno último modelo y
carísimos y esto es algo que afecta a
prácticamente todos a los diputados del
gobierno y a los de la oposición
la policía y los cuerpos de seguridad
tampoco se salvan las extorsiones y las
mordidas son habituales e incluso son
ampliamente conocidos los lazos de
miembros de la policía con pandillas y
narcos los pandilleros de la mara
salvatrucha en rivera hernández dicen
que la policía les avisa de redadas
inminentes y les entregan a rivales
capturados para que los ejecuten a
cambio de un monto que va de 440 a 2.200
dólares por cabeza
sonia nazario periodista estadounidense
ganadora del premio pulitzer políticos
cuerpos de seguridad pandillas narcos y
por último la oligarquía económica
[Música]
y familias que controlan prácticamente
todos los recursos económicos y no han
tenido problemas en pagar sobornos y
situar en los poderes políticos a
personas de confianza para generar no un
modelo de mercado ojo sino un modelo que
vive del control de las instituciones
pues bien todos ellos amigos forman un
entramado muy extractivo de recursos y
tienen la responsabilidad última legión
duras no sea ese paraíso en la tierra
que comentábamos al principio de este
vídeo pero antes también mencionamos al
gobierno de eeuu a la administración
trump como un posible responsable de lo
que ha ocurrido con las elecciones en
honduras así que a ellos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el peso de washington
aparentemente podríamos pensar que
honduras bueno no es un país nada
importante para washington verdad pues
no no exactamente lo cierto es que duras
tiene cierto peso en la política de eeuu
y lo tiene por tres razones principales
[Música]
primero por que una gran parte de los
vuelos sospechosos de transportar droga
desde sudamérica tienen su primera
parada en este país segundo porque hace
dos años ante la enorme crisis que vivía
el país 18.000 niños hondureños que
viajaban solos llegaron a la frontera de
eeuu y en washington nadie quiere que se
repitan cosas así y tercero porque
tradicionalmente honduras ha sido un
país aliado de hecho aquí eeuu tiene
desde hace décadas una base militar es
por todo ello que la potencia
norteamericana ha gastado en los últimos
años cientos de millones de dólares en
honduras para tratar de revertir los
problemas que hay en este país pues bien
en la administración trump lo tienen
claro apoyan a juan orlando hernández
atentos a estas palabras de un destacado
asesor republicano
washington ha invertido dinero
significativo en centroamérica para
ayudar a cambiar la seguridad
y económica si hernández pierde las
elecciones los eeuu no tendrán socios
efectivos en la región la efectividad de
nuestros miles de millones de dólares
estaría en riesgo y más gente podría
estar tentada a venir a los eeuu si el
apoyo de washington es claro de hecho la
policía entrenada y financiada por eeuu
ha participado en los sucesos post
electorales sin queja alguna de la
embajada estadounidense
y es que el gobierno norteamericano
también tiene cierto temor a los bajos
que la candidatura de salvador nasrallá
podría llegar a tener con el régimen
cubano o incluso con la venezuela de
nicolás maduro algo que por cierto el
candidato niega tajantemente se
equivocan porque mi modelo es la
izquierda moderada de uruguay o de chile
o la derecha moderada de costa rica una
cosa es la amistad que mi socio
ideológico no es zelaya tiene con maduro
o morales y otra cosa es lo que pienso
yo que seré el presidente en fin amigos
para todos los que nos estáis viendo
desde honduras es importante recalcar
que las cosas pueden cambiar y suelen
cambiar ahí tenemos por ejemplo el caso
de colombia
mientras tanto mucho ánimo y ahora turno
para ti crees que estamos ante un golpe
de estado déjanos tu respuesta en los
comentarios y también en esta encuesta
si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo
no te olvides de darle a like un saludo
y hasta la próxima con los plantamos en
la calle es que juan orlando hernández
tiene que salir abuela sabes por qué
porque hace cuatro años él dijo nadie
está por encima de la ley y en lo que
nosotros estamos feriantes
[Música]